Jean-Lou chrétien se trouve maintenant
depuis une semaine à bord de la station
m ce vol représente pour la France un
investissement de 140 millions de francs
et il ne faudrait pas croire que le
cosmonaute français montait là-haut pour
le plaisir de faire des pirouettes de
jouer de l'org électronique ou même de
compter le nombre de tours de
[Musique]
terre l'essentiel de ces journée
consiste à travailler durant 6 à 7 he
sur une série d'expériences médicales
tech cela jours sur
7 dans cette salle une vingtaine de
scientifiques du Centre spatial de
Toulouse su minute par minute le
déroulement des opérations à la fois
pour guider les manipulations de
jeanloup mais aussi pour adapter les
expériences en cas de situation imprévu
une liaison communique en permanence les
informations directement au laboratoire
à Toulouse nouses de vérifier la qualité
des
enregistrementsu par jeanlrétien qui en
CE est en train de dessiner une ellipse
avec l'extrémité du doigt
euh d'après les résultats de la prise de
sang là c'est pas très méchant mais il
faut que tu boives plus les médecins
nous disent ici qu'il faut que tu boives
beaucoup ouais mais le Robin il est en P
il est
c'est écoute bois du thé alors pendant
les 23 jours de ce séjour dans la
station jeanloup va avoir à réaliser
plusieurs expérience de physiologie
humaine dont l'une dont je peux vous
parler aujourd'hui celle qui concerne
l'étude du
savoir les modifications du regard
pendant un séjour de longue durée
c'est-à-dire l'étude de l'utilisation de
l'œil et de la tête pour regarder une
cible qui apparaît dans le champ visuel
et savoir comment les choses s'adaptent
au cours d'un séjour prolongé il arrive
que parfois jean-l chrétien menace de
faire passer par le hublot les matériels
des expériences jugé trop désagréaable
ou trop contraignant physiquement mais
il finit toujours par faire ce que lui
demande les scientifiques après tout
c'est pour eux et pour la science que
jeanloup est là forire la tête en bas
pour voir si ça change quelque
chose